- Especially I don't like this pants,
and I hate your shoes, and I don't like
your hanging, you know, clothes here.
You know, this hat doesn't looks good,
I like your hair without it.
- Okay, so you hate everything.
- Let me see it.
- No, no, no, no!
(playful music)
- He wear too tight front.
- Very casual, like she's ready to dance.
- Pants, you know, I don't like too baggy.
- (Eugene) Drop crotch.
- (Min-Young) Drop crotch.
It looks like somebody
coming out from the kitchen.
- I wish you'd wear more skirts.
- It shows your armpit, so I
hate it. (laughs) Oh, Eugene!
- Not excited at all.
- I am, I am!
(happy ukulele music)
- [Ashly] Ooh.
- [Cookie] Oh that's cute.
- [Kane] Medium.
- [Lien] Medium.
- [Eugene] Medium or small.
- [Min-Young] Oh, small
is too tight for you.
Because you, now, your size it went large.
- Thanks.
- What size is this?
- Extra large.
- Yeah, looks much better than this shirt.
- [Cookie] Pink, baby pink.
- This is the extent of
the pink that I wear.
- Large. Here.
- That's, I'm not a large!
- [Min-Young] No. I don't want it.
- This is your size,
right? The arm is good.
- Yeah, I guess.
- Oh, this is for work. Look for work.
- [Cookie] Oh Snoopy! (laughs)
- Oh my. (laughs)
What are the odds?
- My mom likes it 'cause it looks Chinese.
- Yeah, because we are Chinese.
- You like it?
(Lien laughs)
- Oh I love this one.
I'm trying to read
Shish kabob!
(electric guitar music)
- [Cookie] Orange is happy, orange is
the new black! Yes, yes.
(Cookie laughing)
(Ashly screaming)
- Get me out of here!
- [Min-Young] Now he looks
like my son. (laughs)
- [Lien] Wow, you look handsome.
- My mom wants to know
that I can play tennis,
whenever I want. (laughs)
- Feel like an insurance agent.
- Cowboy, taxi, cab driver
- Or like a cocaine dealer in the 80's.
- Eugene.
- Okay, fine.
- And she just looks so cute.
- Linen, no go running.
- You see looks much better,
all the shape is good,
not too baggy.
- Because it's, I like the
tennis, 'cause then, you know how
Serena Williams is like
this, and then like, woo!
- There's a lot of excess clothing.
- The blazer is too
baggy, don't you think?
- Oh no, it looks good.
- Why four pockets?
- Because Chinese style always like that.
You know because four pockets,
they mean, "Oh, I have a lot of money."
- My mom's inner ego is this outfit.
- As much as we disagree on clothes,
if it comes down to it, I will wear
whatever my mom wants me to wear,
because she pushed me out of her,
and that sucks more than me having to deal
with this ugly ass jacket.
- Hey they give you a lot, lucky money.
Put four here, four here, and...
Kane, cut short hair.
- I got a mohawk and she didn't like it.
- Oh Kane, you like Mister
T, Mister T? (laughs)